bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct c'est l'épilogue d'un feuilleton
parlementaire épique à l'Assemblée
nationale le 49-3 déclenché sur la
réforme des retraites la première
ministre a donc décidé de passer en
force sous les oppositions sur le
fondement
la responsabilité de mon gouvernement
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 voilà la réforme des
retraites est donc adoptée sans vote à
l'Assemblée nationale on va revenir dans
le détail bien sûr sur les conséquences
politiques motion censure remaniement
dissolution va-t-on vers une crise
institutionnelle et sociale majeure dans
notre pays comment réparer les dégâts ça
vous regarde spécial épilogue sur les
retraites c'est parti
[Musique]
cette séance restera dans les annales
parlementaires la première ministre a du
cirprendre à deux fois avant de pouvoir
engager sa responsabilité il était 15h10
à l'Assemblée saine surréaliste
chaotique dans l'hémicycle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc pour l'image du jour à
l'Assemblée l'opposition de gauche
pancartes à la main en tenant la
Marseillaise ce 49-3 peut être très
lourd de conséquences eldam Elsa mongava
est avec nous en duplexe depuis la salle
des quatre colonnes pour le décryptage
politique et vous le voyez que Clément
Perot et place de la Concorde ou une
foule de manifestants c'est rassemblée
de façon spontanée depuis cette annonce
du 49-3-7 après-midi et puis en plateau
une grand témoin ce soir la
constitutionnaliste
anne-charlaine bézina bonsoir Myriam on
a besoin de votre regard de
constitutionnaliste pour comprendre ce
qui peut se jouer dans les prochains
jours et puis quatre députés sur ce
plateau Nicolas turquois bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être là député MoDem de la
Vienne Véronique louvagy bonsoir et
bienvenue bonsoir député les
républicains de l'Orne sur la ligne
Ciotti Marleix il faut le préciser vous
auriez voté cette réforme si elle avait
été soumise au vote Alma Dufour bonsoir
et merci et d'être là député la France
insoumise de scène maritime et puis
Victor Catteau bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes député rassemblement national du
Nord voici donc comment Elisabeth borne
a justifié le recours au 49-3
bonjour sur le texte du Parlement
l'incertitude plane à quelques doigts
près on ne peut pas prendre le risque de
voir 175 heures de débat parlementaire
s'effondrer on ne peut pas prendre le
risque de voir le compromis bâti par les
deux assemblées écartés on ne peut pas
faire de Paris sur l'avenir de nos
retraites cette réforme est nécessaire
voilà Nicolas turquois et beaucoup de
tensions aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
avez vécu personnellement cette cette
séance comme une épreuve oui tout à fait
c'était j'étais partagé entre une forme
de spectacle et de se dire tiens on est
présent sur cet événement
la France insoumise d'un côté le
rassemblement national de l'autre un
spectacle qui me mettait mal à l'aise
parce que c'était une profonde on abîmé
la démocratie profondément cet
après-midi
démocratie abîmée par qui est-ce que ce
passage en force 49-3 c'est aussi votre
échec ce soir celui du gouvernement et
de la majorité il y a sûrement des
conséquences à en tirer parce que il y a
des choses qui pourraient être qui
pourraient être redites après je crois
que l'échec ce serait quand ce système
de retraite va être planté parce que
c'est ce qui va arriver on va avoir un
défaut sur notre dette dans les
prochaines semaines si nous ne faisons
rien il y a une tension économique
mondiale globale du fait de l'inflation
du fait de ce qui se passe en Ukraine et
nous devons aussi faire ces réformes
pour garantir la solidité de notre
système le monde est très dangereux en
ce moment vous n'avez pas le sentiment
et je fais circuler la parole d'avoir
rajouté de la colère à la colère déjà
avec cet outil particulier de la
Constitution j'aurais clairement préféré
qu'on voit dans mon groupe on s'était
clairement exprimé pour qu'on vote
il y a une telle tension et il y a eu un
certain nombre de de parlementaires qui
peut-être sous la pression peut-être sur
des choses qui étaient peut-être un peu
scénarisées j'en sais rien comment ça
s'est passé mais toujours est-il que il
y avait plus de certitudes et il faudra
il fallait c'était un choix entre
prendre le vote et les risquer de ne pas
pouvoir continuer l'examen il va
sûrement y avoir il va sûrement y avoir
d'émotions de censure assume qui assume
le leur vote contre et bien il faudrait
qu'il assume à ce moment-là bon alors si
c'est pas votre échec c'est peut-être
l'échec de la droite Véronique nouvelle
vie c'est évident qu'il n'y avait pas de
majorité pour ce texte sinon il n'y
aurait pas eu de 49,3 et le et le
gouvernement aurait pris le risque d'un
vote vous regrettez j'imagine ce passage
en force mais est-ce que les
républicains ont pas une part de
responsabilité ce soir alors pour ma
part je regrette de passer en force
j'aurais préféré également un vote juste
dire qu'au niveau des républicains nous
nous sommes positionnés sur le texte qui
n'était pas le nôtre nous avons essayé
de faire évoluer le texte sur le fond en
poussant un certain nombre de nos
propositions en refusant certaines
alternatives qui avaient retenu le
gouvernement initialement je rappelle
que dans le premier enfin dans le projet
de loi avant même qu'il soit présenté en
Conseil des ministres il y avait une
volonté de relever l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite à 65 ans nous sommes
opposés à ceci voilà donc sur le fond
nous avons contribué nous avons
participé après sur la forme je pense
qu'il y a eu un certain nombre d'erreurs
de la part de gouvernement et dire que
c'est l'échec du gouvernement
et d'ailleurs la première ministre n'a
pas dit exactement à la même chose à la
pas été tendre avec les républicains à
la tribune elle a pointé la
responsabilité de certains LR et sur la
même ligne je vais vous faire écouter
votre collègue du MoDem Bruno millienne
vous lui répondez juste après très bien
et je suis excessivement déçu par leur
irresponsabilité aujourd'hui le LR n'est
plus un gouverneur un parti de
gouvernement pour terminer ce sont des
un groupe d'opportunistes qui ne pensent
qu'à leur réélection nous n'avons pas eu
uneanimité dans notre groupe nous avions
une majorité mais il est très clair et
vous le savez que la majorité n'ont plus
n'était pas unanime et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela que manifestement il n'y avait
pas une majorité franchement Véronique
louvager est-ce qu'il a pas un peu
raison Bruno Millen du MoDem quand il
dit
ils se sont des opportunistes ils
regardaient leurs électeurs et ils ont
fait un peu double jeu je voudrais juste
te dire que du côté de la majorité
depuis quelques jours la majorité ne
faisait pas le plein au niveau de son
ombre de voix c'est peut-être ça qui a
changé en quelque temps juste dire
également que si le gouvernement a fait
le choix de retenir un PLFSS pour ce
projet de loi retraite c'était parce que
dès le début il avait anticipé et
imaginé de pouvoir recourir 49-3 puisque
cela lui permet effectivement de ne pas
user de son droit tirage c'était écrit
pour 49-3 oui d'ailleurs le gouvernement
avait même imaginé je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez de d'introduire ce
projet de loi retraite par amendement
dans le PLFSS donc sur la forme je crois
qu'il y a c'est la responsabilité
aujourd'hui du gouvernement c'est
l'échec du gouvernement il y a eu un
certain nombre d'erreurs d'ailleurs en
matière de communication sur un grand
nombre de points et effectivement le
fait que le gouvernement est dès le
début retenu un outil comme un PLFSS
rectificatif révèle qu'il avait
l'intention finalement d'utiliser le cas
on va y revenir avec vous à une certaine
médina sur l'outil constitutionnel
choisi parce qu'il est très spécifique
elle m'a Dufour dans quel état d'esprit
vous êtes ce soir pour la France
insoumise le combat continue vous étiez
à la Concorde où je parle on y
retournera tout à l'heure j'étais à la
Concorde ou de pendant plus de trois
heures où l'ambiance électrique les gens
sont écœurés moi aussi je suis écœuré
moi je viens d'acheter lui sur un
département de Seine-Maritime qui se
mobilise énormément là on m'a dit que ça
se passe tellement mal au Havre que les
tramways circulent plus qu'il y a des
feux ce qu'on commençait à prendre dans
les rassemblements spontanés en France
au début qui disait qu'on abîmait la
démocratie mais attendez on parle de
quoi là on parle d'un passage en force
sur une réforme qui va concerner tous
les Français c'est ça qui abîme la
démocratie que vous le vouliez ou non
les Français n'en peuvent plus mais
c'est à nous de l'usage on peut se poser
la question et nous on le dit côté
France insoumise depuis bien longtemps
mais je pense qu'on est de plus en plus
nombreux au de la même au sein de la
nuit passe mais même je pense je sais
pas ce que ce que d'autres parties en
pensent mais je pense qu'il y a de plus
en plus de Français qui ne veulent plus
de ce régime ou le gouvernement peut
passer en force sur le Parlement et dire
on allait perdre on sait pas trop
peut-être gagner peut-être perdre à de
vous après donc du coup on passe en
force sur le Parlement donc pour vous le
combat continue dans la rue il faut que
le gouvernement retire cette réforme
même vous êtes adopté par le Parlement
avec la méthode qu'on le connaît on le
dit depuis le début
on le sait 90% des actifs sont opposés à
cette réforme à peu près 80% des
Français 60% des Français même sont pour
le blocage du pays pour faire reculer le
gouvernement le gouvernement n'a pas la
légitimité démocratique de passer en
force sur ce texte il essaye de le faire
très bien ça aura des conséquences moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on abime la
démocratie et moi je veux pas retourner
chez moi avoir des gens qui me disent ça
sert à quoi de voter vous servez à quoi
en fait parce que nous on vous aime bien
on voit que vous vous battez mais en
fait ça sert à quoi donc à un moment
donné ça ça a des conséquences il faut
pas s'étonner après s'il y a plus de la
moitié des Français qui votent pas aux
élections législatives tout ça ça trouve
ses racines aussi dans la manière
d'exercer le déboucher politique ce sera
l'abstention pour vous ou la dissolution
rassemblement national Victor Catteau
Marine Le Pen a été très dure
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale pour
elle les institutions sont dénaturées le
principal responsable c'est la première
ministre écoutée il y avait une majorité
de députés contre ce texte une majorité
de Français contre ce texte et ils font
passer ce texte de force
c'est donc incontestablement une
dénaturation de notre fonctionnement
démocratique pour faire passer une
réforme donc chacun admet qu'elle est
brutale injuste
inefficace
injuste et injustifiée d'ailleurs donc
je pense que Madame borne doit partir
elle n'a rien d'autre à dire que la
gifle qu'elle vient d'envoyer au visage
des Français en leur disant vous êtes
opposé à cette réforme les députés sont
opposés à cette réforme et pourtant nous
ferons deux forces passer cette réforme
ça n'est pas admissible alors elle a
annoncé elle-même qu'elle a accepté
d'être le fusible banco qu'elle saute
c'est pas un peu facile tout de même de
réclamer tout de suite la tête de la
chef de l'exécutif elle Elisabelle borne
estime elle l'a dit elle l'a tribune
aujourd'hui que le RN est resté tapis
dans l'ombre du débat parlementaire
alors c'est pas forcément vrai ici
effectivement on a assisté à un double
échec un double échec une fois tantôt
pour le gouvernement est tantôt pour la
démocratie pour le gouvernement parce
que en utilisant l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution il démonte qu'il est
impuissant et qu'il n'a pas les armes
pour pouvoir gouverner comme il le faut
et pouvoir faire passer un texte comme
celui-ci mais c'est aussi un échec pour
la démocratie parce que tout le monde
sait sur un texte aussi important que
les Français et que les Français
d'ailleurs repoussé ne voulaient pas
qu'il ne fallait pas utiliser un article
comme celui-ci c'est une c'est un
article qui est un article de cas social
d'un article qui qu'il faut utiliser
avec prudent alors il est effectivement
constitutionnel mais sur un cas aussi
sensible que celui-là il n'était pas
adapté alors est-ce que vous dites ce
soir la même chose que la France
insoumise il faut retirer ce texte et
j'appelle à manifester vous le
rassemblement national à qui n'avait pas
défiler dans les cortèges et moi je
pense qu'effectivement il faut retirer
ce texte ce texte n'est pas le bienvenu
les Français ils sont totalement opposés
plus de 80% des Français sont opposés
plus de 90% des actifs le sont également
il ne correspond pas à ce que veulent
les Français et quand on est député on a
également dans l'intérêt des Français
mais pour les manifestations les
Français sont libres de manifester
effectivement c'est pas dans l'ADN du
rassemblement national de manifester de
la cité au manifestations
on laisse la liberté à chaque Français
sachant que dans les cortèges on a aussi
que grand nombre d'ouvriers qui votent
pour Marine Le Pen donc on a absolument
aucun problème avec les manifestants qui
du coup se mobilisent pour contrer le
gouvernement et pour refaire entendre
leur voix alors on va venir sur les
différents outils de procédure sur la
table pour protester contre ce passage
en force Anne Charlène bézina la
démocratie est-elle la grande perdante
ce soir est-ce qu'il y a eu un excès de
forceps constitutionnel sur le Parlement
on a parlé du 47 1 on a parlé du vote
bloqué au Sénat et le 49 3 pour terminer
je trouve ça toujours délicat d'entendre
des chèques de la démocratie à partir
représentative Voilà la démocratie
représentative s'exprime quand même et
où le peuple peut aussi avoir les canaux
pour s'exprimer néanmoins c'est vrai
qu'on a eu ici et c'est inédit sous la
Cinquième République il faut le dire
l'usage de tous les mécanismes du
parlementarisme rationalisé qu'on a mis
en place sous la Cinquième République et
dans beaucoup d'autres régimes
parlementaires mais précisément pour
discipliner généralement des majorités
hostiles ou courtes et
ce choix préalable du véhicule
législatif du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif à d'ores et déjà en fait un
produit un débat parlementaire qui
allait être forcément braqué etc alors
j'ajoute que on est en train de se
demander l'échec de qui l'échec de quoi
l'échec aussi du dialogue parce que
c'est vrai que la majorité relative
avait été présentée en tout cas quand on
a vu ce résultat de sortie des urnes
comme peut-être une opportunité pour la
démocratie
c'est ça c'est avant tout arriver à se
mettre d'accord avec peut-être des
parties d'opposition ou des parties qui
au départ ne vous sont pas directement
on va dire affiliés dans un contrat de
majorité et le compromis n'a pas été
possible aujourd'hui le compromis on est
dans ce premier échec de la majorité
relative en nous montrant que le
compromis n'a pas été possible et je
crois que c'est vraiment ça la plus
grande blessure qui peut en ressortir
c'est que notre régime parlementaire
n'arrive pas à s'adapter à l'idée de
créer des contrats de coalition
peut-être sur un texte et peut-être
aussi que nos oppositions n'arrivent pas
forcément non plus à construire quelque
chose d'alternatif et à démontrer des
postures d'utilité donc il y a eu un peu
un échec partagé à mon avis de tout ce
que de tout ce que la démocratie peut
nous montrer parfois de de difficile
deux tiers des Français n'ont plus
confiance dans nos institutions c'est la
dernière grande étude du Cevipof la
démocratie abîmée peut être aussi par le
spectacle parlementaire qu'elle a donné
ça dépend qui vous dit ça il y a des
gens qui sont tellement en colère qui
nous disent merci de dire les choses
merci de secouer entre guillemets ce
débat parlementaire lénifié ou on a
l'impression que les gens qui discutent
sont très très très très très très loin
de nos réalités il y a des gens qui
pensent pas ça il y a des gens qui
disent vous criez etc je vais être
honnête je vais être franche il y a les
deux moi je reçois avoir des gens qui me
disent merci d'être là et vraiment ça
m'arrive beaucoup il y a aussi des gens
qui me disent bah ouais vous pensez pas
que des fois vous devriez baisser un peu
le ton etc évidemment c'est des
questions de forme la France c'est
heureusement pluriel les gens sont
différents on a des électorats aussi
sûrement assez différents ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il faut pas confondre les
apparences et la réalité la réalité
c'est ce que je disais c'est ce qui
abime la démocratie les gens sont pas
idiots les gens ils se contentent pas de
regarder des spectacles les gens ils
savent très bien ce que ça veut dire un
49-3 ils savent très bien ce que ça veut
dire une majorité relative ils savent
très bien ce que ça veut dire quand un
gouvernement passe en force c'est ça
c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'on parle et je
voulais quand même rebondir sur c'est
pas la première fois qu'on voit que le
gouvernement échoue à faire des
compromis parce qu'aucun majorité
relative ça pourrait aussi dire que
quand des fois et c'est arrivé pendant
le budget que la gauche est la droite se
mettre d'accord pour voter des choses je
rappelle qu'on avait par exemple voté
des crédits supplémentaires assez
conséquent sur la rénovation des
bâtiments ou sur la relance du
ferroviaire aux côtés des républicains
donc là je sais pas ce qui peut être la
plus pure et ma nation d'un
parlementarisme ou alors là il y a la
nups LR RN enfin je sais pas tout le
monde vote pour la même chose et on nous
roule quand même dessus à coup de 49-3
donc moi je suis désolé à un moment
donné le gouvernement depuis le début
montre que contrairement à ce qu'il a
affiché il n'a aucune culture du
compromis avec le Parlement dans son
ensemble dans son ensemble est-ce que
vous répondez à ça la culture du
compromis c'était le mantra d'Elizabeth
borne qu'il a répété moult fois dans sa
déclaration politique générale on n'est
pas là du tout je voulais revenir sur
quand même ce qui s'est déroulé sur
cette réforme des retraites
effectivement il y avait un effort qui
était demandé et qui conduisait à ce que
les Français en moyenne travaillent deux
ans de plus ça c'était un effort réel
parce qu'on arrive devant une impasse
financière majeure mais d'un autre
élément parce que notre système de
retraite est complexe parce que il est
il est très différent il y a plein
d'injustices il y a des injustices sur
les droits familiaux les gens sont plus
venus me voir je sais pas quels sont mes
collègues mais de pas comprendre alors
pourquoi les enfants sont considérés
enfin ça donne droit à 8 8 trimestres
dans le dans le privé et que quatre dans
le public pourquoi les fonctionnaires
qu'elles ont calcule
il y a des erreurs de communication dans
la présentation de la réforme au départ
il y a eu des erreurs de commise mettre
cette réforme sous l'angle de la justice
notamment après ce qu'on avait sur la
1200 euros sur les femmes il y a des
éléments je n'entrai pas dedans j'aurais
fait différemment en termes de de
communication il fallait beaucoup de
pédagogie le je dirais il y a une forme
de rentrer dans le domaine des retraites
les gens ont perçoivent j'étais là au
moment du système universel de retraite
c'est au moment où on parle des
retraites qui se disent tiens les
retraites sont faibles mais c'est une
réalité les retraites sont faibles en
France tiens il y a un fort écart entre
les retraites des hommes et des femmes
mais oui il y a 40 % qui reflètent des
carrières qui
vous dites c'est pas nous c'est
systématiquement les retraites qui sont
urticantes dans le pays je dis pas que
c'est pas nous il y avait il y avait des
éléments d'explication on avait demandé
nous au Mouvement Démocrate de de
rallonger avait ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure ça pouvait passer sous forme
d'amendement dans le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale nous
disions il faut plus de temps
d'explication on avait l'espoir
d'emmener le procédé législatif choisi
n'a pas vos faveurs c'était le plfs
cesse au tout début on parlait
d'amendement
mais il fallait du temps d'explication
mais ce temps d'explication avec le mode
d'intervention de de notamment de LFI où
on pouvait même pas s'exprimer où on a
passé des heures et des heures sur des
sujets qui étaient certes il y a eu un
compromis qui a été prouvé en commission
mixte paritaire et énormément des
apports des républicains ont été repris
pour ne pas dire à la quasi totalité
écoutez Aurélien Pradier qui
manifestement le frondeur de la droite
n'y trouve toujours pas son compte c'est
un échec cuisant pour le gouvernement
rendez-vous compte la gravité de
démocratique de la situation je ne vois
pas comment ce texte sur la réforme des
retraites qui n'a été que trop mal
discuté qui est rejeté par nos
concitoyens dont je considère qu'il est
profondément injuste et je l'ai dit
depuis le début je ne vois pas comment
ce texte peut-être aujourd'hui adopté
aux forceps il y aurait là une rupture
démocratique dont les conséquences sont
à mon avis largement sous-estimés quant
à savoir si c'est un échec pour ceux qui
ont combattu la réforme des retraites
pas vraiment si nous en sommes là c'est
sûrement parce que quelques dép y
compris chez les républicains mais aussi
ailleurs on fait entendre une parole qui
n'était pas une parole forcément
équivalente à tous mais qui était une
parole que nous avions le droit
librement de porter pardon de dire
revenir vas-y mais est-ce qu'on font les
républicains n'avaient pas intérêt aux
49-3 est-ce que ça ne fait pas vos
affaires est-ce que ce n'est pas
exactement ce que vous souhaitiez en
ayant joué avec les nerfs du
gouvernement alors écoutez pas du tout
nous avons eu encore une réunion de
groupe hier soir nous étions très clairs
et nous voulions aller au vote quasiment
tous y compris Aurélien Pradier
franchement y compris Aurélien Pradier
voilà à partir de
la commission avec des positions certes
qui étaient différentes un certain
nombre d'entre nous d'ailleurs
quelques-uns en votant contre pour le
dire très clairement
acté au niveau de la CNP réviser leur
vote voilà certains qui étaient
déterminés à être contre s'orienter vers
l'abstention mais moi je dire que
l'outil législatif qui a retenu le
gouvernement contrit à contribuer à une
erreur très forte parce que nous n'avons
pas eu toutes les facultés de déposer
des amendements dans un texte financier
nous ne pouvons pas leur en tout cas
d'aimer un petit peu de temps mais mais
il y a eu des erreurs de la part du
gouvernement à la fois en termes de
communication parce que le gouvernement
a voulu faire de ce sujet la
communication la communication ce sont
je dirais des mots chocs et des
raccourcis or sur un texte des retraites
qui est un texte en fait très technique
on collègue le disait il y a des tas de
cas dérogatoires des tas de cas
particulier des ajustements qui doivent
être fait en fonction des situations
différentes le public
à faire adopter des rêves voilà mais
nous vous ne pouvez pas faire de la
communication sur un texte de cette
alors on va rien de la pédagogie et ça
ça n'a pas du tout été fait alternance
en tout cas quelque chose à réfléchir du
côté du groupe en tant que tel de la
discipline de groupe parce qu'en fait
vous le dites une réunion hier aboutit
finalement vraiment un
résultat et finalement on voit que il y
a beaucoup de personnalités qui se
jouent à l'intérieur donc est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a pas ici quelque chose à
réfléchir du côté de votre groupe au
niveau de la discipline ou en tout cas
au niveau de la cause moi je vous dis
franchement vous ne pouvez pas dire ça
de cette manière sur ce texte dès le
début je veux juste dire que ça n'est
pas notre texte nous avons travaillé sur
un texte qui n'est pas le nôtre avec des
orientations très différentes certains
voulaient aller même jusqu'à des
dispositifs du capitalisation collective
avec oui tout à fait nous là
de cette nature voilà et nous sommes
persuadés qu'il faut faire la retraite
la capitalisation collective parce que
un moment les équilibres démographiques
tels qu'ils existent ne permettront plus
il n'y aura plus suffisamment d'actifs
pour payer les retard en tout cas c'est
parce qu'elle a été retenu dans la
Commission mixparité on va se concentrer
sur l'étape d'après c'est le dépôt
d'émotion de censure elles a mon Agava
explique et nous exactement ce qui va se
passer maintenant vous êtes celle des
quatre colonnes à l'Assemblée oui vous
voyez la pression et le monde c'est
largement retombé depuis tout à l'heure
alors l'émotion de censure on sait que
le rassemblement national va en déposer
une ça devrait être demain ensuite et le
rassemblement national a aussi dit qu'il
vautrit toutes les motion de censure
déposées ensuite il y a une motion
transpartisane qui est diligenté par le
groupe liotte des députés du groupe Yot
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire alors ils ne sont pas assez
nombreux pour pouvoir déposer une motion
mais la nuit pèse est d'accord pour leur
donner les signatures manquantes en
acceptant et bien de d'être sur une
motion transpartisane il y a quand même
quelques conditions c'est que celle-ci
ne soient pas signée par du
rassemblement national et on le voit
normalement la nuit pêche accepte de
signer cette motion transpartisane mais
bien si toutes les composantes de la
nups sont acceptés dessus une autre
motion donc ces deux motion devrait être
discuter soit lundi soit mardi merci
beaucoup Elsa on vous retrouve un peu
plus tard dans l'émission vict le gâteau
le rassemblement national votera
toutes l'émotion de censure quel que
soit le groupe qui les dépose alors oui
parce qu'on a une ligne de conduite on a
été lu sur un programme nous avons
toujours dit que nous étions opposés à
cette réforme des retraites et nous
avions toujours dit qu'effectivement
nous voterions dans l'intérêt des
Français ce n'est pas le blind test qui
fait effectivement du sectarisme quand
on dépose d'émotions éternelle parce
qu'on aurait pu effectivement envoyer ce
texto référendum pour que les Français
puissent s'exprimer la nuit pêche a
décidé de ne pas le voter cette notion
référendaire et de pouvoir de ne pas
ainsi pouvoir donner la parole aux
Français nous voterons l'émotion
l'émotion de censure nous déposerons
également une motion de censure nous
savons que le sectarisme de certains ne
permettra pas probablement qu'à
l'aboutisse mais effectivement nous
considérons que l'intérêt des Français
va au-delà de l'intérêt partisan et que
sur un électricien important que
celui-ci il est important les trois
motions la vôtre la nuit pèse et la
transpartise alors Elsa y a-t-il une des
trois motions qui a une chance d'être
adoptée et que le gouvernement soit
renversé bien écoutez Myriam
heureusement on n'avait pas rangé nos
calculettes pour le de la réforme de la
retraite alors les oppositions dans leur
ensemble elles comptent 262 membres à
peu près la majorité absolue celle qui
est nécessaire absolument pour faire
passer une motion de censure elle est à
287 voix il manquerait donc environ 25
voix alors les opposants à la réforme
des retraites espèrent les trouver et
bien à droite justement sauf que Eric
Ciotti le président du parti est Olivier
Marleix le président du groupe ont été
très clair il ne signeront pas et ne
voteront pas de motion de censure mais
on le sait leur parole n'engage pas tout
leur groupe certains députés LRS disent
réfléchir ils auraient aimé que leur
groupe dépose une motion de censure
alors ils disent de ne pas vouloir voter
une motion sur lequel il pourrait y
avoir de l'extrême gauche par exemple
mais d'autres députés à l'air disent ne
rien s'interdire et réfléchir pendant le
week-end voilà à nouveau merci beaucoup
à Elsa les républicains qui détiennent
les clés cette fois de la de la censure
vous savez qu'il y en a qui sont tentés
par cette motion transpartisane alors en
revanche au niveau du puis il est clair
nous ne déposerons pas de motion de
censure et nous n'en signerons pas et
nous n'envoûteront pas c'est la consigne
collective et majoritaire
du groupe
isolés voilà de manière individuelle
certains probablement
voteront rajouter du chaos comme le
directoutisme de voter une chanson je
pense que nous sommes et je le redis
nous sommes un parti de gouvernement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
voulu participer sur le fond à
aménager pousser nos propositions sur le
projet de loi retraite et nous nous
voulons construire nous ne voulons pas
déconstruire et aujourd'hui voter une
motion de censure c'est faire tomber les
institutions c'est clair mais faire
tomber les institutions pourquoi pour
dès demain renommer un gouvernement de
même de même nature qui serait peut-être
un gouvernement borneus
décidera mais mais finalement si c'est
le cas
le lendemain voilà donc non
si le président de la République a envie
de dissoudre il le fera il est encore
d'hier et à chaque fois finalement on
sent que c'est arme et présenté et
actionné quand il en a envie c'est lui
qui détient ça et un point justement tu
me renverses je te dis sous ça c'est la
constitution du régime Parlement
Emmanuel Macron la première d'ailleurs
c'était à l'automne dernier lors d'un
dîner si le gouvernement est renversé
renversé il choisira de dissoudre est-ce
que c'est une vraie arme de de
dissuasion massive ou est-ce que tout
est possible aujourd'hui alors je crois
vraiment que tous les scénarios sont sur
la table que constitutionnellement cette
arme n'existe pas uniquement en réplique
de la motion de censure il faut le dire
déjà ça n'est pas obligatoire et ça
n'est pas particulièrement traditionnel
une seule fois sous la Cinquième
République une dissolution a fait suite
à une notion de censure et c'était le
général de Gaulle qui a quand même
réussi à doubler le nombre de députés
qu'il a eu ensuite donc encore faut-il
bien basculé aussi ce moment de la
dissolution mais oui je pense que ce
scénario est forcément nécessairement
sur la table puisque on a parlé
plusieurs fois de l'arbitrage des
Français
cette avantage que nous donne le régime
parlementaire est toujours de dire que
en cas de crise institutionnelle si
vraiment les institutions en tant que
peine n'arrive plus à s'entendre la
dissolution est censée représenter cette
arme de sortie de crise ou le seul
arbitre c'est le peuple donc c'est
possible néanmoins c'est vrai que on
peut être gêné un petit peu par cette
idée que la dissolution soit utilisée
peut-être pour discipliner peut-être
pour faire peur et on voit pas forcément
ici quelle cohérence elle aurait eu par
exemple notamment après la première
lecture étant donné que ça aurait mis
fin à l'avenir du texte donc il y a
peut-être un discours aussi qui doit
être travaillé autour de cette
dissolution parce que elle n'est pas
aussi évidente que cela son issu me
paraît très incertaine comme celle de la
motion de censure finalement mais c'est
vrai que vous parliez de partie de
gouvernement c'est ce qui est un petit
peu difficile à entendre en ce moment
c'est à dire que on se dit est-ce qu'il
existe encore des parties qui peuvent
travailler avec cette majorité est-ce
que finalement l'accord qui devait être
scellé aujourd'hui n'était pas celui qui
était le plus important pour cette
législature et quel sera finalement
l'avenir de cette majorité courte sans
pouvoir c'est une majorité presque sans
aucun allié Alma Dufour vous avez peur
de la dissolution pas du tout non pas du
tout un sondage interactif qui arrive
s'intératif qui circulent beaucoup et
qui a beaucoup été d'ailleurs transmis
au journalisme par la majorité le
gouvernement qui montre que tout le
monde perd au législative sauf le
rassemblement national qui gagne des
sièges moi je pense honnêtement que
quand on veut je l'ai dit j'en suis
profondément convaincu on a vraiment la
crise démocratique qui va être temps de
la regarder en face il va être temps de
la regarder en face il faut lutter
contre l'abstention par tous les moyens
et moi je pense qu'on peut pas avoir
peur du peuple si on veut résoudre la
crise démocratique donc non j'ai pas
peur de la dissolution
pas peur de la écouter au point où on en
est aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr je la souhaite je peux vous
dire que les manifestants là en tout cas
ceux qui sont dans la rue ils ont envie
de revoter ça c'est clair ça c'est clair
et on peut pas continuer comme ça à un
moment donné effectivement après ce
passage en force dans la crise qu'on
traverse la crise multifactorelle ça a
été dit effectivement le monde est
chaotique le monde est en danger on est
dans des grandes périodes de turbulences
et je pense que l'équilibre qui s'est
dégagé à l'Assemblée nationale
manifestement de satisfait personne
alors les sondages donnent effectivement
bon pour l'instant des équilibre qui
reste globalement les mêmes mais je
pense qu'il va y avoir une campagne moi
je pense que les gens
sauf le rassemble on n'aurait pas et je
la c'est un appel que je fais aux
Français qui aurait pas 50% d'abstention
parce que malheureusement quand on est à
ces chiffres-là forcément tout assemblé
elle est qu'à moitié légitime et c'est
normal et que les gens se rendraient
compte que le pouvoir leur appartient si
s'ils vont tous voter aussi Victor catho
vous vous n'avez pas peur de repartir en
campagne ah non parce que partir en
campagne c'est se représenter dans les
Français et encore une fois on est élu
par les Français on doit rendu compte
aux Français donc forcément vous gagnez
des sièges et c'est sondages ne vous ont
pas échappé mais vous vous imaginez au
fond ça rajouterait pas de la crise au
fond est-ce que les Français peuvent
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
jouer si d'un 49-3 on rentre dans une
véritable crise politique mais je pense
que les Français comprennent
parfaitement et je pense que ce qu'ils
en train de se passer l'effet beaucoup
réfléchir et se rendre compte que le
gouvernement actuel la majorité actuelle
n'est pas prête à gouverner en tout cas
n'est pas tout à fait apte à gouverner
je pense qu'effectivement les soirs je
voulais prendre avec beaucoup de
pincettes parce qu'effectivement les
sondages à l'époque ne donnaient 15 20
sièges on s'est retrouvé avec 89 députés
et je pense qu'effectivement le sondage
là pourrait effectivement donner
beaucoup plus de députés que le sondage
actuel et ce sont des à 5% on est les
seuls à la présidence
qu'effectivement le la dissolution est
un est un outil constitutionnel et que
nous n'avons pas peur en tout cas au
rassemblement national de repartir
devant les électeurs parce que c'est à
eux qu'on doit rendre des comptes et au
vu de ce qui se passe je pense
qu'effectivement c'est peut-être
nécessaire vous vous rendez compte quand
même dans quel moment politique on est
on contrainte de parler d'une
dissolution possible
comment vous réagissez là clairement par
rapport à la situation nous on estime
que la situation notamment financière
parce qu'il y avait quand même une un
enjeu financier notamment financière et
très grave sur la pérennité du régime
dehors traite et sur le financement
global de de de
notre pays donc c'est très clair il va y
avoir vraisemblablement lundi une motion
de censure que ceux qui ne partagent pas
cette approche qui sont contre la
réforme l'assume et qui le vote en toute
confiance en républicains cette censure
vous êtes plus confiant moins fébrile
j'ai beaucoup d'estime pour Madame
louvagi la qualité de son travail je
pense qu'il y a certains certains de
certains de de de ses collègues qui sont
qui sont qui sont pas les meilleurs amis
finalement du du groupe les républicains
et qui précisément monsieur Pradier
monsieur Pradier tire dans tous les sens
je je pense qu'il abîme d'abord sa
propre famille donc je peux entendre
qu'il y a des sujets qui ne pouvaient
pas porter mais je pense qu'il abîme
d'abord sa propre famille donc les sons
laissons les faire prenons nos
responsabilités puis et puis nous
verrons oui c'est vrai que c'est
important de dire qu'on change de
logique quand même parce que si on s'est
compter pour les pour aujourd'hui on se
compte pour les contré c'est pas du tout
la même démarche au point qu'on a pu se
demander justement si le groupe LR avait
pas plus de difficultés à voter pour
puisque justement il y a une affiliation
vous parliez du retour dans les
territoires et c'est vrai que les
députés ont à vivre cela ce qui peut
parfois être un peu plus tendu alors que
voter contre c'est un engagement pour la
destitution c'est ce qu'a voulu
justement la Constitution de la
Cinquième République c'est qu'on ne
compte pas les abstentions on ne compte
pas les personnes qui ne s'affinent pas
contre et c'est vrai que la démarche en
tout cas elle est elle est complètement
différente politiquement et c'est vrai
que beaucoup de députés LR ont changé un
peu de sociologie électorale ce sont des
zones rurales dans lesquelles les 64 ans
voilà ont un effet important et ils
disent tous ceux qui sont frondeurs la
fin de la droite notre électorat ne nous
le pardonnerait pas si on avait du voter
oui je crois aussi et peut-être surtout
que nous avons été élus sur une forte
dimension personnelle des uns et des
autres ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas
d'autres
collègues par votre partie semblablement
il y a une forme de liberté qui s'exerce
les frais il faut le dire mais moi ce
qui me aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai
été très perturbé devant la séance que
que nous avons vécu parce que quand je
vois l'état du pays par rapport à sa
souveraineté financière ça c'est ouvert
une telle énergétique une souveraineté
alimentaire également voilà donc c'est
vrai qu'il nous faut redresser ce pays
parce que nous avons des tas de richesse
mais il nous faut voilà et puis de
l'autre côté il y a une colère des
Français une colère des Français
certains s'expriment dans la rue
certains voyaient venir leur colère dans
la rue mais elle existe cette colère
donc il faut aussi l'entendre il faut
que le gouvernement entendre mais il
faut apporter des solutions mais ça
n'est pas je dirais en appelant au cas
où ça n'est pas je dirais en hurlant
comme on a pu l'entendre dans
l'hémicycle ça n'est pas en faisant de
l'obstruction sur les textes ce sont que
nous puissions débattre voilà on a parlé
des conséquences politiques je vais
garder une conséquence peut-être un
levier le rip qui est compliqué le
référendum d'initiative partagé vous
aviez déjà déposé une motion et ferder
pour demander à référendum on garde ça
pour la suite mais on vient en mouvement
social parce que ils sont dans la rue
les Français depuis qu'ils ont entendu
le 49-3 pas tous bien évidemment mais
quand même c'est notable des
manifestations spontanées un peu partout
en France on va voir quelques images à
de la place de la Concorde c'était en
fin d'après-midi alors que le 49-3 était
annoncé aux alentours de 15h20 ils sont
là les manifestants étaient très clairs
ils ne veulent pas lâcher bien au
contraire ce 49-3 leur donne encore plus
envie de manifester bonsoir Clément
perbot vous êtes place de la Concorde
pour LCP alors dites nous dans quel état
d'esprit sont les manifestants mobilisés
et bien les manifestants sont en train
de quitter cette place de la Concorde
pourquoi parce que les forces de l'ordre
sont intervenues depuis maintenant 15-20
minutes avec des gaz lacrymogènes il y a
eu également quelques charges de CRS et
donc la foule est en train d'être
dispersée vous pouvez voir sur ces
images d'Emma Chala les manifestants qui
sont en train progressivement de quitter
la place de la Concorde pour gagner la
rue de Rivoli ici place de la Concorde
nous sommes pratiquement à mi-chemin
entre l'Assemblée nationale et l'Élysée
c'est donc un lieu très symbolique et
c'est ici spontanément que la foule a
décidé de sortir de ce rassembler dès
l'annonce du 49-3 par Elisabeth borne on
voit des manifestations des manifestants
particulièrement en remontées ils
perçoivent l'utilisation du 49-3 comme
un acte d'autorité est très fort et ils
sont je vous le disais particulièrement
remonter je voyais des manifestants par
exemple qui me disaient qu'il n'aurait
jamais manifesté si la réforme avait été
votée cet après-midi mais que c'est à
cause de ce 49-3 qui sont décidé de
sortir dans la rue Clément l'intercédait
qu'elle s'est réuni au siège de la CGT à
Montreuil ce soir pour décider quoi
précisément sur la suite à donner au
mouvement
alors l'Inter syndicale a appelé à une
nouvelle journée de grève et de
mobilisation ce sera jeudi prochain le
23 mars de ce que je peux voir de ce que
je peux entendre de la part des
manifestants il y a une vraie volonté
maintenant de poursuivre le mouvement il
me disent que le 49-3 ne fait que
renforcer encore leur motivation mais
aussi et bien qu'il y aura peut-être un
durcissement dans les prochains jours je
voyais par exemple une femme d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui me disait que
jusqu'ici elle avait fait tous les
rassemblements que tout s'était passé de
façon très pacifique mais que désormais
peut-être elle participerait à des
blocages certains manifestants nous
disent que maintenant il va falloir
peut-être durcir le ton donc voilà
peut-être que le dialogue social va se
durcir dans les prochains jours Alma
Dufour merci beaucoup Clément Perrault
depuis la place de la Concorde Alma
Dufour vous avez beaucoup défilé il y a
eu 8 journées d'action on sent bien que
la radicalisation peut voilà arriver et
le mouvement social peut se radicaliser
il y a même une note des renseignements
généraux qui craint ce scénario là vous
le souhaitez
encore une fois c'est marrant parce que
c'est nous qui devons nous justifier de
ce qui n'est pas normal dans ce pays
c'est-à-dire que bah non on souhaite pas
que les gens sont déjà se mettre en
grève on le rappelle quand même quand
les gens se mettent en avis ils perdent
du salaire donc c'est pas en ce moment
surtout avec l'inflation c'est pas si
simple on souhaite pas nécessairement
qui est des blocages parce que ça ça
emmerde tout le monde on va dire ça très
clairement si vous pouvez pas circuler
enfin etc c'est une évidence mais la
question c'est encore une fois pourquoi
un gouvernement se sent institué de
cette légitimité démocratique qui n'a
pas pour faire cette réforme et puis on
pourra revenir sur les finances qui est
franchement c'est pas comme ça que vous
allez redresser les comptes publics vu
les peu d'économies qui vont être faites
à la fin dans 10 ans avec cette réforme
vraiment et on a qu'à déjà pas conclure
de la dette assise sur l'inflation pour
essayer d'éviter d'aggraver la crise on
pourra reparler des finances parce que
c'est trop facile de dire c'est très
fort mais elle tombe du ciel elle est
nécessaire financièrement sur les
blocages sur les bois bien que la
tentation on va voir comment d'ailleurs
la terre syndicale et l'unité syndicale
se perdure dans la durée ou pas on sait
que leur et plus voilà circonspect même
si depuis le 49-3 il y a toujours une
unité syndicalement fait la
démonstration encore une fois que non
seulement il passe en force sur le
Parlement il a pas la légitimité pour le
faire depuis le début et en plus il
écoute pas les manifestants il y a eu
3,5 millions de manifestants pardon mais
ça fait très très très très très
longtemps qu'il y avait pas eu autant de
manifestants dans la rue et ça tout le
monde s'en fiche donc du coup bah
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous vous donnez
évidemment forcément vous donner aux
gens l'impression ce qui est vrai
personne dans la rue rappelons-nous des
gilets jaunes qui étaient bien moins
nombreux mais qui étaient violents eux
ont fait céder le gouvernement comment
vous réagissez à ça
je pense que c'est c'est pas ce niveau
de mobilisation mais pour autant il y a
une mobilisation importante ça c'est
vrai il faut il faut l'entendre et c'est
si vous allez pas en année vous pouvez
pas savoir non mais à un moment donné
c'est des mouvements extrêmement forts
on a rarement vu ça en France il faut le
reconnaître
la mobilisation la mobilisation
forcément on pense aux gilets jaunes
aussi la taxe carbone a été retirée et
là vous avez un mouvement pacifique une
unité syndicale un pays quand même il
est où l'opinion qui est constante à la
fois sur l'adhésion aux manifestants et
contre le recul de l'âge légal qu'est-ce
que vous faites avec ça
je reconnais que la mobilisation est
forte 2 je reconnais qu'elle était elle
était
plutôt bonne enfant c'était hier ou
avant-hier sur devant devant les
Invalides je suis passé c'était plutôt
bon enfant et ça il faut le reconnaître
et c'est et c'est à l'honneur des
pensées que ça va continuer à être bonne
enfant après le 49-3 je pense qu'il va
falloir signal je pense qu'il va falloir
un signal
en termes d'expression il va falloir que
le gouvernement le gouvernement ou le
président s'exprime sur sur le sujet
alors Elisabeth borne est sur TF1 ce
soir et puis on vous donnera les
informations si elle nous parviennent
c'est un élément c'est un élément
important il va falloir sortir de cette
situation de blocage elle peut rester
pour vous au Gouvernement
de la République en fonction de des
équilibre qui pourra qui pourra trouver
mais il faut envoyer je pense un signal
fort pour renouer avec avec le retrait
de pur et simple de la réforme ou le
blocage c'est ça maintenant l'équation
mais on en est là et encore une fois
voilà on a fait la démonstration qu'il y
avait quand bloquant qu'il y avait qu'en
coûtant de l'argent à l'économie ou
quand on menaçant de violence que ça
marchait c'était terrible en fait encore
une fois encore une fois on revient sur
la crise démocratique donc oui voilà
pour répondre clairement on appelle
évidemment les Français à faire grève à
soutenir les blocages et d'ailleurs on
appelle on leur dit de se renseigner il
y a des caisses de grève il y a plus de
3 millions d'euros dans des caisses de
grève y compris la nôtre au moment parce
que nous
trois depuis le début comme on sait que
l'issue se jouera forcément dans la rue
bah nous on soutient vraiment
contrairement au RN les manifestants et
les blocages parce que ce qu'on veut en
priorité c'est que cette réforme soit
retirée on se contente pas de parler et
donc voilà donc oui bah oui mais on en
est là mais ça nous fait pas plaisir
alors la question des blocages et la
question de la radicalisation comment
vous vous situez là-dessus au
rassemblement national alors je suis le
mouvement est totalement en faveur de
manifestations dès lors qu'elle respecte
effectivement tout le monde et je pense
que les blocages finissent par
sanctionner les Français quand on bloque
une raffinerie on bloque les Français
les petites gens qui se rendent au
travail et qui n'ont pas la possibilité
de lescendre dans leur voiture donc ce
genre de blocage nous sommes évidemment
pas favorables mais effectivement contre
deux ans de leur vie
je ne suis pas de jeu du genre à vouloir
priver les Français d'aller travailler
ces gens qui ont besoin de travailler
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure vous
avez dit qu'il y avait un problème
d'inflation les Français qui n'arrivent
plus à finir les fins de moi et je ne
veux pas avoir sur la conscience cette
cette faute et cette problématique
selon vous ce mouvement social cette
colère dans le pays quelle trace elle va
laisser slow beaucoup de problématiques
parce qu'effectivement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que Elizabeth borne
emmenait à son onzième 49-3 en l'espace
de neuf mois elle est dans quelques mois
elle sera au point de rejoindre Michel
Rocard qui a 28 c'est une c'est
extrêmement grave les Français nous le
disent sur le terrain qui sont
effectivement
surpris et assez face à ce constat ils
ont un désarroi qui est qui est
compréhensible parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas gouverner de façon aussi durement
sans prendre en compte les aussi les les
oppositions et prendre en compte
évidemment le scrutin parce qu'il faut
pas oublier que en juin dernier il y a
eu des élections et que le la majorité
s'est retrouvé en majorité relative il
faut composer avec ça en France
aujourd'hui
la question qui se pose aussi c'est dans
quel moment politique on est est-ce que
ce pays peut être encore réformé ou
est-ce que cette crise si vous reprenez
ce mot ou pas d'ailleurs ça m'intéresse
de le savoir et ben va nous mettre dans
une forme de statu quo et marquer une
forme de fin de quinquennat parce que
aucune forme de réforme ne sera ne sera
possiblement votée dans l'hémicycle je
comprends tout à fait je vais faire un
petit retour avant de répondre à votre
question sur sur une question qui s'est
posée plusieurs fois de légitime de
légitimité démocratique que ce
gouvernement n'aurait pas je crois que
c'est quand même intéressant de redire
que le résultat de sortie des urnes est
de toute façon une légitimité
démocratique ça il faut quand même le
rappeler il y a un problème moi je pense
qu'il y a un problème c'est qui a
représenté dans l'hémicycle l'Inter
syndical qui a finalement réussi la
cristalliser ce mouvement du peuple
certainement pas la majorité mais
l'opposition non plus finalement n'a pas
vraiment réussi ce moment qui avait
réussi en 95 ou la rue a été représentée
dans le Sénat des assemblées où il y a
eu une force un petit peu par rapport à
ça et donc je me demande aujourd'hui si
le si le problème n'est pas aussi on a
parlé de d'un fossé qui se creuse entre
la démocratie représentative et la
démocratie sociale peut-être que cet
élément à jouer un rôle aussi dans dans
le circuit qui aurait pu se passer entre
entre les syndicats et les partis
politiques mais c'est une question sur
laquelle vous vous allez sûrement
m'apporter votre réponse non mais je
réponds directement et je pense
qu'effectivement ça échappé à personne
que entre disons les têtes de réseau à
la fois partis et syndicats c'est vrai
que ces derniers temps ça a pu ça a pu
être plus compliqué mais clairement pas
des politiques
également vous croyez qu'on parle pas au
bas syndical vous pensez que ça se passe
mal ça se passe très bien
de représentation par eux mais bien sûr
que si mais moi encore une fois j'étais
en manifestation tout à l'heure ou sur
tous les blocages qui ont lieu sur ma
circonscription mais mais non seulement
ça se passe bien mais en plus il nous
demande comment cette opposition
apporter de d'arrêter ne se sentait pas
représenté donc faut quand même
prendre ça et j'entends sur le
territoire des gens qui peuvent être
comme partout par rapport à la réforme
comporte mais mais pour autant il ne
supporte pas vos façons d'intervenir à
l'hémicycle d'empêcher le débat de de
s'en prendre physiquement
psychologiquement à des uns et des
autres il y a eu des députés qui ont été
en très grande souffrance qui sont là
ils sont légitimes ils ont été élus
comme vous et donc il va falloir trouver
des compromis ma question elle porte sur
l'avenir est-ce que le quinquennat est
au point mort est-ce qu'il sera possible
de trouver une majorité par exemple sur
un texte très compliqué aussi à venir
sur l'immigration avec la droite avec
une partie de la gauche ou pas ou c'est
fini on y arrivera pas
dans mon approche de de de
du parti modem il faut aller vers les
autres il faut aller vers les autres
parties qui soient à gauche qui soit à
droite même si sur certains aspects je
ne je ne partage pas tous les éléments
c'est une nécessité pour la France je ne
vois pas dans l'état actuel et au vu de
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui comment
en restant sur la majorité
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire des réformes majeures
donc il faut il faut aller les
institutions là il faut les deux tiers
du Parlement à Versailles l'immigration
texte très compliquée on comporte on
portait un moment donné
dans notre partie quelque chose autour
de la proportionnelle dans le sens où il
faut il faut un certain nombre de
majorité de coalition alors je sais pas
au vu de au vu de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui si ça si ça renforce cette
notion de proportionnelle mais pour moi
que ce soit sur la droite ou que ce soit
sur la gauche il faut faire des
des compromis pour arriver à sortir la
France de l'ornière parce que la France
est dans l'ordinaire ce soir alors je
vous le disais Elisabeth borne est-elle
invité du 20h de TF1 elles avaient pu
suivre cette intervention de la première
ministre katal dit au terme de cette
journée particulière à l'Assemblée elle
est encore en train de parler la
première ministre mais elle l'a redit
jusqu'au dernier moment elle le
président de la République et ses
ministres ont cherché une majorité pour
aller au vote mais constatons qu'il leur
manquait quelques voix ils ont engagé la
responsabilité du gouvernement alors
Elisabeth mondes ce qu'elle a redit
c'est qu'elle a donné la responsabilité
à la droite aux républicains qui ont
manqué à leur responsabilité elle a
aussi elle s'est dit très choquée par le
comportement des oppositions dans
l'hémicycle disons que certains groupes
d'opposition ne respectaient pas les
institutions oui alors est-ce qu'elle
est en sursis d'après vos informations
Elsa écoutez elle est évidemment
fragilisée vous saviez c'est Elisabeth
borne qui avait demandé un peu plus de
temps pour essayer de parvenir à un
compromis c'est donc évidemment un échec
alors tout à l'heure en réunion
intergroupe avec les trois groupes de la
majorité elle a été applaudi elle a été
soutenue mais les députés gardent un
goût amer beaucoup voulaient aller au
vote elle a eu cette phrase jamais mon
destin personnel ne me fera prendre une
décision que je juge contraire à
l'intérêt de mon pays certains y ont vu
une marque de courage d'autres un
semblant d'envoi merci beaucoup
on verra ce qu'il en est dans les heures
dans les jours qui viennent Véronique
louvagi au chaos des retraites est-ce
qu'il rend impossible la possibilité
d'ouvrir d'autres chantiers de réforme
ou pas je crois que le dossier des
retraites toujours un dossier compliqué
parce qu'effectivement c'est c'est
une réforme impopulaire voilà je crois
que tous les exemples des réformes de
retraite et nous en avons eu un 2010 la
réforme verte 2003 fillons à chaque fois
il y a une forte mobilisation cela a été
difficile j'ai changé avec Gilles Carrez
il y a quelques jours qui a vécu tout
tout ces différents projets et il me
remémor un certain nombre d'anecdotes de
vécus et je crois que c'était très
difficile mais comment continuer à
réformer vous l'état d'esprit c'est quoi
il y aura des voies de passage dans
cette émission nous n'avons pas nous
n'avons pas la culture en tout cas du
compromis en France entre les familles
politiques nous ne l'avons pas il faut
le reconnaître force et de constater que
le paysage politique a changé lors de
ces dernières élections législatives
donc il faut travailler
cette culture du compromis de la
coalition alors peut-être pas la
coalition mais en tout cas du travail en
commun et ça nous ne savons pas faire
très important je parlais d'immigration
mais il y a pas que ça il y a l'école il
y a la transition écologique avec les
investissements il y a aussi l'hôpital
tout ça vous êtes prêt quand même à
co-construire pour ce compromis ou au
fond c'est la guerre de tranchée qui
commence ce soir
très clairement
non nous on n'est pas prêts à
co-construire parce que encore une fois
si vous vouliez vraiment un compromis le
gouvernement aurait mis plusieurs
options sur la table il y a les comptes
publics il y a la dette publique ont
déjà nous on pense très sincèrement que
la dette publique à ce stade et les
parents boursables mais ça on a eu des
débats longs sur le sujet très important
qu'il en soit non mais du coup il y a
des options la réforme des retraites
faire croire aux gens que c'est la
réforme des retraites qui va régler le
problème des comptes publics c'est
franchement c'est franchement une très
grosse arnaque parce qu'ouvrir
parce qu'en fait ce qui m'agace beaucoup
c'est que on nous présente vraiment à
chaque fois la réforme comme une
nécessité financière absolue si on avait
vraiment voulu construire des compromis
déjà rien que sur ça s'agit quand même
de trouver aux alentours de 20 milliards
en 2030 c'est pareil en 2030 mais
attendez qu'est-ce qu'on fait en ce
moment on supprime encore 16000 oui mais
là on vient de supprimer on va supprimer
avec la suppression de la c.be 16
milliards par an dès maintenant par
d'ici 2030 dès maintenant donc on
continue à faire des choix qui aggravent
notre déficit notre capacité justement
vous aviez d'autres
nous pour nous c'est vraiment une
question c'est très très simple en fait
le monde est ça pour le coup sur le
constat je suis d'accord le monde je
l'ai dit traverse une période de grande
turbulences là on est tous d'accord
là-dessus on a juste pas du tout du tout
du tout les mêmes réponses je pense que
le néolibéralisme sous quel que soit se
faire qu'on pratique depuis les années
80 nous emmène dans le mur donc à ce
moment-là il y aura pas beaucoup de
compromis possibles à la marge avec ce
constat qui nous oppose profondément en
tout cas
on est bloqué et la démocratie
représentative est en panne ce soir on
va terminer avec la question du
référendum peut-être que c'est une une
potentielle sortie par le offre c'est
Fabien Roussel qui milite pour le
référendum d'initiative partagée
j'ai pris des décisions en faveur de la
fille
le président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée Fabien Roussel qui lui je
vous le disais veut et bien actionner un
outil constitutionnel le référendum
d'initiative partagée on écoute
aujourd'hui la suite c'est le rip le
référendum que nous allons déposer
défendre et pendant les 9 mois qui vont
suivre pour obtenir ces 4 millions de
signatures cette réforme devra être
suspendue et donc nous avons encore
l'espoir de l'emporter de faire
respecter le monde du travail et de
créer les conditions que cette réforme
ne soit jamais mise en application en
rendant le pouvoir au peuple
bézina vous avez une minute pour nous
dire ce que c'est que le référendum
d'initiative partagée et s'il a une
chance d'aboutir alors le référendum
d'initiative partagée c'est une nouvelle
procédure qui existe dans notre
Constitution depuis la réforme de 2008
et qui en fait vient aménager la
procédure de référendum qui normalement
est vraiment unilatérale entre le
président et le peuple le référendum
d'initiative partagée c'est une
rencontre en fait entre 1/5 des
parlementaires et un dixième de la
population c'est une proposition de loi
qui va donc lancer l'initiative
parlementaire et qui ensuite ouvrira au
recueil des votes alors il y a plusieurs
formalités c'est-à-dire que cette
proposition de loi référendaire beaucoup
de conditions elle est très conditionnée
par l'article 11 qui nous dit déjà
qu'elle ne peut pas avoir un objet
abrogatif immédiat donc là on est quand
même dans quelque chose de très tendu
parce que quand bien même évidemment la
proposition loi ne proposera pas
directement d'abroger la réforme des
retraites elle aura cet objet de plus ou
moins l'interdire de se mettre en
application et il y a une première année
4 millions de signatures allez un
dixième du corps électoral avant même
d'en arriver au recueil des signatures
le Conseil conditionnel doit donner un
avis sur la constitutionnalité ou non de
cette proposition et l'objet abrogatif
immédiat me paraît quand même déjà
beaucoup de douteux sur la première
étape sur la seconde vous l'avez dit il
faut près de 4 millions 9 je crois de de
signataires au niveau de la population
le dernier référendum d'initiative
populaire que nous avons connu en 2019
n'en a obtenu je crois qu'un petit
mignon donc c'est toujours le président
de la République qui décide c'est
toujours le président de la République
qui décide bon voilà c'est pas encore le
bout du tunnel sur cette question
vous restez avec moi on va s'arrêter sur
les retraites si vous le voulez bien
merci déjà d'être venu débattre mais
vous allez le voir il y avait pas que
les retraites à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
c'est un Bourbon Express particulier ce
soir qui nous est présenté par
thibaultenock on l'accueille tout de
suite
bonsoir Thibault bonsoir avez-vous
accueillir pour conclure cette émission
je disais il n'y avait pas que les
retraites la commission d'enquête sur le
nucléaire à auditionner deux
personnalités de taille oui deux anciens
chefs de l'État auditionnés par
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas tous
les jours que ça arrive c'est un
événement plus rare même que le 49-3
c'était une première sous la Cinquième
République c'est François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozy qui ont donc répondu aux
questions des députés de la commission
d'enquête sur l'énergie ils ont dû
justifier leur choix en matière de
nucléaire pendant l'exercice de leur
mandat alors que retenir de ces grands
euro de près de trois heures et bien
d'abord l'absence de mea culpa les deux
présidents ont défendu bec et ongles les
choix qu'ils ont fait pendant leur
quinquennat pour Nicolas Sarkozy le
soutien indéfectible au nucléaire même
après Fukushima l'ouverture d'EDF à la
concurrence pour François Hollande
l'objectif de la réduction de la part du
nucléaire à 50% et la fermeture de
Fessenheim en résumé a de rares nuances
près si c'était à refaire c'est de la
refré la même chose il ne regrette rien
écouté
j'ai pris des décisions en faveur de la
filière nucléaire quelle que soit le
prix politique à payer et je l'assume je
dois reconnaître ce que j'ai fait
assumer et le faire encore devant vous
mes décisions j'assume que je suis pour
l'ouverture à la concurrence je
revendique cette décision
fermer alors mais alors si tout est pour
le mieux dans le meilleur des mondes
atomique comment répondre à la question
qui taraude la commission d'enquête
pourquoi la filière nucléaire se
retrouve aujourd'hui si mal en point
avec une capacité nucléaire la plus
faible depuis 35 ans et bien réponse de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est la faute de
François Hollande
les signaux désastreux politique
idéologique qui ont été envoyés j'ai dit
ça serait une folie je visais l'accord
PS Europe Écologie de novembre 2011
quand même prévoyait 24 fermetures sur
58 réacteurs on voulait tuer la filière
alors vous en doutez l'intéresser à
écouter l'audition de son prédécesseur
le matin même et quelques heures plus
tard et bien il lui a répondu dans une
sorte de dialogue à distance il a été
pour certains tentants de faire des
polémiques est-ce un défaut
d'investissement qui expliquerait
l'arrêt momentané de près de 26
réacteurs est-ce un doute sur la
pertinence du nucléaire lié une posture
politique non il a été établi que la
cause a été provoquée par la découverte
d'un phénomène de corrosion sous
contrainte
de fissures mais alors d'après l'ancien
président socialiste qui est responsable
d'après vous et bien Nicolas Sarkozy
François Hollande a longuement critiqué
la mise en concurrence d'EDF vrai raison
selon lui de l'affaiblissement du
nucléaire au terme d'une loi prise en
2010 par Nicolas Sarkozy une conquérance
fossée a-t-il dit par le fameux
dispositif de la reine décidé par son
prédécesseur s'il y a une décision qui a
été contraire à la filière nucléaire
c'est bien la loi de l'homme de 2010 pas
simplement la mise en concurrence mais
une concurrence faussée cette loi a
privé EDF de ressources alors voilà pour
le retour à l'envoyeur alors mais dans
cette histoire il manque quelqu'un me
direz-vous Emmanuel Macron il a été
question de l'actuel président avec un
traitement différencié Nicolas Sarkozy a
été plutôt clément Emmanuel Macron n'est
pas en cause dans la fermeture de la
centrale de Fessenheim a-t-il dit
François Hollande lui a eu la dent plus
dur il a déclaré qu'Emmanuel Macron
avait je cite délibérément EDF du fait
des décisions prises l'an dernier dans
le cadre du bouclier tarifaire vous le
voyez dans ce débat entre président sur
le nucléaire on est loin de la fusion
quel chute merci beaucoup tibohenoc pour
ce papier très complet sur ces deux
auditions présidentielles de
d'importance on reviendra bien sûr sur
les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête parlementaire merci beaucoup à
vous quatre d'être venu débat pas le
temps de vous faire réagir c'est un peu
de ma faute désolé et merci à vous Anne
Charlène bézina dans le fauteuil du
grand témoin ce soir demain une émission
pour poursuivre sur justement la crise
de la démocratie représentative 19h30 à
demain très belle soirée sur SCP bien
sûr
[Musique]